yeah so now we are live and so this is
gonna be Ryan Chester place two people
people don't know for about one minute
until that thing updates okay so now we
are live like you can see it over here
and then so people will start cheering
in about one minute
this will say st. Louis chess club right
it takes 60 seconds or so okay and then
once people see that they're gonna start
challenging and then can I see their
rating levels
yeah you're gonna get challenges way up
here those got swords alright so as soon
as people see us you know there's like
zero people watching right now let's go
logistically if I need to go upstairs
you can just take over yeah let's do
whatever so so we should do like long
yeah that's up to you so you can pick
the time control otherwise students can
challenge you to whatever okay I was
doing five minute Mike office does one
minute other people have done longer
time controls it doesn't matter we got a
you know mr. senior section very cool
right what the back to mum time you
towards okay so we only have about an
hour today okay so because it takes a
little bit longer because you're talking
right now there's too many buttons
buttons on this mouse okay what is that
what do you do I don't know but yeah
some people show up otherwise they'll be
able to see all this on youtube if
they're not watching it no okay okay so
far so good but yeah we're here with
Ryan Chester club manager who will be
here on Wednesdays is usually gonna be
three or was that one-time thing mister
no no I'll be three you always do three
three or four yeah
Custer doesn't have to be good just fast
you are better chess our first comment
from drunk lifeguard lifeguard wait a
minute you know that no audio technical
superstar way in the background now
we're also joined by Danny Machuca this
doesn't say people but clearly drunk
lifeguard service Oh
all right Caleb Caleb that's been
watching not a cab damage no not a caleb
we know he's from some other country
I've already forgotten which but good to
see you again Caleb people are watching
doesn't tell me hey codex so new
children tried like a 10-minute you guys
want a challenge okay let's do like a
10-minute challenge just hang out here
hopefully people jump up just leave it
here yeah hopefully they jump up isn't
that challenge menu now yeah beats me
doing work we do okay so good people
actually hit my chest I want to see if
we're on the main screen like we really
should be there it says gym st. Louis
and it says Ranchester so yeah an
abnormally low number of people but
maybe most people just can't handle yeah
hold on Baltimore's okay
you're caught you're caught you're
hunting Connor all right yeah it's all
it's all coming in now we're getting
allowance did you put it in yep it's
right casual what's up on the facts Ryan
Chester what is your USCF mmm is it
above a thousand I don't think it's
above a thousand yeah yeah so uh all
right simmer down yeah you don't play a
whole lot though don't play a whole lot
1033 1033
oh you're above a thousand now look at
that unless I'm somewhere in a dark
corner shouting out sometimes we let
Bensimon out of the dark corner
peri-peri - that's also a basis
well yeah if you guys are interested in
challenging club manager Ryan Chester
we're looking for a 1000 challenges and
we don't have all that much time so we
might get to a whole lot of people so
get your challenges in now so far
developed all the stuff I do enjoy the
noise and makes it right into this is
yours do you tell us - if you're Tony
you want to be on the stream no it's
good we got Ryan Chester it's the first
ever Ryan Chester plays the people off
to a fantastic start here under that
bishop tips on you Voldemort because
we're secretly playing Jonathan shrugs
right is this the part where you take
okay good we got some position we can
take it from Eric Thank You Anne
it was a good segment wait are you just
chilling oh okay
can you see it yeah
this is one way to play against the
French and then there's some face that's
like probably making fun of you it looks
like it's got what I said a week or is
this a week ten I'd be pressing yeah
yeah Brian is on a roll today he picked
a good data stream all right
you know this looks totally fine for you
should be eating crumbs it's fun to
listen to the stream call the cheater
don't listen unless we're not helping
you only listen if we're distracting you
you're gleaning all of our insight so
that's the other problem is sometimes it
feels like there's a big delay and then
some days it feels like there's no delay
so everybody is listening so you gotta
like thank you drunk lifeguard yeah you
can do it
cheer up buddy there's a little cheer up
buddy thing that's a good move here mr.
de maras so yeah if we tell moves though
then like they're gonna hear - which is
right right right we need some way to
have like a larger leg because then we
can like I want to what I'm doing it I
always wanted like to be able to give
comments and stuff this is definitely a
leg right cuz I'm pointing now and I
don't see it
yeah but wait it doesn't take as long as
you think right it's different every
single time
mine is number one thank you drunk the
lifeguard drunk lifeguard all right but
codex was not trying to degrade you
thank you codex yes you meant in the
nicest way possible okay
I normally only play three minutes okay
you don't seem to be too rattled by all
the talking stuff cuz even I can see one
bar was here too it was like you could
tell he was glad that I'm like doing the
chat oh yeah cuz it's it's a totally
different thing when you're like talking
and yeah but he also thinks a lot that's
why it's not allowed on camera up here
b6 b6 c 6 just try to ignore various was
impossible yeah c6 we should have buried
in the analysis to confuse the seats
that would be a good square of c4
connects both of those rooks
and his queen okay think your queen
should be off the D file because there's
a rook on that balance yeah but don't I
have had to move yeah
wilco be in every play on this channel
do you respond it uh and I just talk
he's listening you're evil so yes yes
when when var is jamming residents he'll
be playing we also might get him he
lives in st. Louis so we can get him to
come back on yeah and so tomorrow
Thursday Thursday is when the jams have
been streaming look he's already only
talking back to us that's how you know
it's pretty tough yes forget
it'll be Dinesh Moorish playing for the
first time so tomorrow yeah he's
dreaming rose no that's right
it'll be a lot of fun to see how he
reacts to this woman I don't know if
he's ever streamed to I don't think so
so a lot of these gems they've never
streamed which is really cool so they're
coming on they're doing this for the
first time they don't know what to
expect which means it's great
opportunity to come and play them so you
just get to play Jam
yeah in this game I'm just chillin out
bringing the mic come earlier party and
my covers on every Friday so that's you
know when most people should tune in my
covers knees and Ryan there's some
reason to grandmaster and then it's all
about my cover
what's up nascar father people put all
these remotes and they have like weird
faces
tell me a second second
yeah so I guess if you taking you trade
everything on t1 then he's gonna take on
c3 in here
with your little chickadees which is
Roger
maybe he's right
can i play this here yeah he said then
he said c6 oh you mean a buncha give us
that he's he's far beyond us well the
mike says hey guys this is
so we don't have enough games to have a
no real rating yes I don't know how many
I mean this is rapid rated so I don't
know right and also this is casual you
can see so if you want to play people
that are like affect our rating you play
like rate of people are you sure cuz
we're crushing people today oh no and
then this drunk lifeguard I think
actually knows like what's up so you can
like table here flip this codex Oh God
hey Jonathan can you recommend a book
video did we do this how about I already
recommended books of video steel also
online for visualizing Ebola um what's
up the coos and I'll just say it again
my favorite book of all time is
mastering chess strategy by Johann
Elston books yeah the art of checkmate
yes yes it's really good really do enjoy
they're all the basic attacks and [ __ ]
leading veterans and suffering no I've
never asked for a book recommendation
huh Muslim somebody else my apologies to
codex maybe it was codex goodbye Emily
Trask do you want to come come join the
stream she's a lot on camera okay she is
all right all right everyone calm down
but there's a female coming to the chest
don't know it's a rare event row by the
stream hi you're not on the camera well
you might be if you're real generate in
between many yeah oh there she is
have fun
alright play the people all right Sammy
that's me yeah whoa Danny almost drink
my coffee taking a sip out of this what
are you taking his sweet time with us
now just drunk lifeguard with all these
i okay so
like something quick don't say number 45
oh he's never don't listen to anybody
okay they're all messing you up okay all
right Oh 94 attacks one time
booked honors the King chess pieces also
full stories but who selects the ones
that are full of stories
those are always interesting thanks
Jonathan appreciate it going to see if
it's readable in Kindle form yeah
probably
mastering chess strategy that's what
took me from 1300 to 1800 just I read
one book I did read the whole thing took
it very serious good to see you John
John's wondering what he should
challenge you to Tenno is what we're
doing like this is know do three three
oh yeah yeah we're skipping five people
during the final so brother I was just
gonna play like h3 here's needs a lift
yeah I know Lucy John in the queue also
if you have some weird username that's
different than your twitch you can tell
us and then maybe we'll play you
but I like looked better when your night
was on e5 cousin after lots of taking on
d4 that sometimes we're taking us in six
at the end
aku's big fan of the Antonine book
probably good stuff
Timmons Titans I assume that's you on to
man can I just go back new there's
another
yeah feels like we're drifting a bit
though but she always hope that we flag
you yeah that's my only hold amorous
that's taking your sweet time name I
can't read on the stream it says great
content thank you very much what rating
is Ryan he's over a thousand being
attacked yeah I didn't understand that
five to be entirely almost seems a bit
weakening to the black position don't no
way didn't just take on d4
it's my not gonna end up back on here at
some point somebody's gonna take
something one of these bombs are gonna
take each other like I said we he's
gonna take on D for some point you're
gonna take back he's gonna take giri has
a book is about is the Gary book in
production like we can buy it now
they're for sale all right I see his
point
okay if you take on c5 then your Knights
going after like trading which out so I
should come back here guys see what just
nothing yeah we're just IMing around is
sixty memorable drugs it's good it's
making an art book on drawing yeah
that's pretty good yeah good job
beep beep delight yeah
yeah we're stopping around support how
to run faster take your time Valle de
maras yes you'll be the second 1900 I
beat today hey here you go JZ asking you
the big question what happened to don't
get four good question good question
it's not over yet we're explaining the
waiting game here it is everywhere
chillin out here oh so just chill just
keep chillin nothing's happening here's
the book is called my junior years in 20
games hardest thing in chess is drawing
the one giri good one it's a good
wittiest anti-magnus tweeds yeah that's
a good giri jokes can i go hunt i want
to eventually get right here yes we know
i can't tell bull de maras ryan working
on his knight moves as Feingold would
say you could still do it
you could do it I just don't know wait a
minute is that phone hanging yet come on
is this pawn hanging yet cuz now it wait
this one singing tell me tell me the
truth is hanging take it is that phone
ringing yet we're not supposed to trust
Danny no no but it feels like that pawn
singing now cuz look you're gonna take
it and then if it trades all the ropes
and your queen ends up on d1 your
opponent he doesn't have a target I
don't notice I don't know what his
movies after all that doing yeah sure
Primos
all right so 245 people for three yeah
well just wait till we get into the meat
yeah so we do ten many games and they
take 20 minutes then we're gonna get
through three games so yeah if you speed
it up
you want three Oh after this after we
crush Valda Morris will move on to the
3o section of this segment
my thought was here was that after all
these trades the night would be
attacking this pawn is that way too like
um yeah I just didn't see a country way
without ever this trade happening you
know well I assume that what happened
you know we we can tell him we'll start
doing you know notation now that he's
like in time okay so yeah you mainly
Glen g6 and then I go see someone with
check I was learning anything now we
have to start thinking about our queen
is going to invade and hopefully check
me out so we can we gotta figure out how
to get our we go in for checkmate or we
can just chill out and laugh so can I go
back to 26 I mean there's robably some
combination of checking an act Queen d8
like randomly check yeah yeah you can
also not check them randomly Queen
decent random okay I trust you you're
the highest rate as the awesomer has a
great work no sir has a lot of great
police M&J super expensive card covers
220 bucks
yes it's working out sure start taking
stuff with check oh yeah I was gonna win
screen check me yes you know who's beg
you Oh Martha yeah yeah whatever we got
here let's go game I'm shy going order I
like the quantex we're yet three minutes
five countdown three arts - alright you
gotta be faster so whatever segment yep
[Music]
[Laughter]
take with them Yvonne in that situation
me or easily dead structure it is
take it okay people are still talking
about books okay they're available just
accessible now are you a big fan of mr.
a guard would invited the guy that
starts the stream to this street
whose
make sure we keep the speed up dog
can you wash your coat in on st. Louis
Chess Club YouTube yes you can
so far we put all of you can watch
everything on our YouTube channel that
we have live streamed so far that might
not always be true so make sure you
check it out live and if you don't have
time most of it will be available on
YouTube at the end so yeah feel free to
go to youtube look up sailor's chess
club find us
a badge position says you're up for
points do you live streaming on Twitch
are you not watching it on YouTube this
is not on YouTube right
you're a person watching this onto it
right now
yeah we do we stream on Twitch Jonathan
do you also do videos I'm doing twitch
for now hopefully I get back into the
classroom at some point I do enjoy it
but for now just hear a moan about the
twitch getting it going and I need to do
it on Tuesdays you can attack that rook
with your knight and the bishop will
just make some random moves wherever you
come up Wilma genius sir just remember
you don't have left so if you take that
bishop in the negative background check
Regent
we watching oh the light chess embedded
oh so you can watch it and are there
other mediums that you can watch like if
it's streaming on something other than
twitch will it still show up on my chest
and I have to say leech s because
apparently that's what's really called
but what's up bird bird is enjoying your
stuff what's the videos on openings
I have no immediate plans to do more
openings though that's what I feel I'm
best at so I'll take it back to a
discipline all right somehow that he
managed to get lots of counterplay cuz
you guys stopped talking to tell me what
to do a lot of points you got no time
you gotta you gotta speed it up you'll
never come up with a winning plan if it
takes a night to do something hang up
take it's fun try to attack his things
and take them
you can embed either YouTube or twitch
on your Lee chest streamer [ __ ] good to
know good to know you taking up to that
Danny
ah brilliant move okay what's gonna take
your bishop and you're gonna come on
come on Tex sir close
he's gonna take a bishop flavored pizza
yeah she's probably in bed with this
king
yeah living lots of moves fast fast so
fast fast and random quick I think you
could do YouTube it doesn't appear on
the side that's about everything else of
every move you got two seconds just has
to be and hope for the best
taking out trade trade trade trade trade
faster trainer train it go up there take
his thing you're gonna win you're gonna
win maybe somehow free movies still
gonna feel real no no you won he won he
wasn't just keep going go go go go go a
little pond you can do it that's why at
the end right context
he put up heavy resistance go yeah so
close thank you thank you hey Taurus
what's up wait Taurus outdoors oh you
got him excited yeah he may be a Taurus
Taurus what time were you born
and how long before this breaks down and
becomes completely different sort of
session he's got the speed now this is
three to those who do get two seconds
and I like this three to yeah me neither
oh my so different from watching my
usual yeah yeah it's certainly this is
only a day one of the Rhine Chester
plays people only get better with time
it's gonna get dangerous
move away
but yeah I think we might get in the
tech here you don't have a lot of pieces
by your king okay
you'll get there I want to move here and
then back over there he wants to like
trash band up trash panda
and then what happens is people leave in
the room and gets really like weird and
eerie for like a few seconds why just
this quiet it's also weird to me because
like you're upstairs and there's like
all this music you know classical music
yeah and then you come down here and
it's really quiet and it's kind of like
unnerving for a few minutes yeah it's
like it's a hard adjustment okay take
back when is Pepe coming
yeah but they will be here mid-february
looking for a 15 fish play the people if
you can call them people who's gonna
stop you yeah yeah very excited about
Pepe so we got um Dinesh Boros will be
here for I guess the rest of January
then we'll have the tennis coleauxv
coming in it sort at the beginning of
February and then mid-february we got
that pick one guy so and we'll all get
him in here so I assume most people have
not actually done this sort of a thing
Pepe is the streamer so he's done stuff
for like just went for and stuff I doubt
there's some great masters you probably
recognize iam stream unless you watch a
beer also you guys should watch on our
YouTube channel between two ponds where
I interview the grandmasters because
we're looking for questions and input
that you guys want to talk about then
it's not like analyzing chess moves its
kind of getting getting to know them as
people more so if you want to talk to
them right yeah this gives you also
another way to connect to him to you cuz
you're gettin on our stream you can ask
us questions and Brian's the man behind
it all so you can you ask a good
question we can ask the very master for
you
yeah just out of it he's not in the game
tonight's gonna deal with this yeah I
can't believe I'm not watching my coke
Finan I'm not last year I'm probably
closer I'm exactly your level you might
be a little bit better than me so don't
different people play on the stream so
this rating is kind of you should be
doing all this stuff on the king´s I
didn't like checkmating is so like yes I
should be in a lot of trouble here put
this here okay you should be in a lot of
trouble at least your bishops gonna get
in if we need it for defense so Bishop
you go to d3 and play little D -
spectators l Dios
I do one piece of advice that I got and
was the one you were being attacked on
the flanks he should attack in the
center do you agree with that yeah
welcome chess worm OTB good move good
move play yeah you should have played
Bishop d3 before because says nice nice
more stories the better can i plug Ben
Johnson's podcast no way don't talk
about Ben Jonson on our street no yeah
Ben's great real like him did he do
something on those ones you know I don't
know but I can't I can't I feel like
eight days or something we're friends on
Twitter yeah so it's weird that he
hasn't it
podcast is what we're talking to it he's
still the best player
but do it let go
I got a minute for you because I need to
be able to have access to f8 because if
his Queens sneaks in he's gonna meet you
in g7 ever see how Queen that's like how
he should check me you please don't
no he's playing Mike you know sighs
Petrecca
you think like we're thinking some
hopefully five somewhere quick like up
in this territory obeyed took the best
hack so be ready with when he tries to
check me you that's dry nice try he's a
traitor
are you a Russian Baha now we have to
worry about his rook somehow getting to
the back rank which isn't possible yet
but he can't get down to the seventh
rank and so what's here's what bad
things gonna do it's gonna play there
and then when you go away from your
agent F bones it's Knights gonna for a
few and no no your phone Hanks I do it
then
you wanna come in the camera we allowed
to talk about politics on the street oh
you're the manager but you guys wrote
for super crush I get it no give us two
second delay all you have to do will
speed it up thank you for the game
though you're undefeated so far this is
pretty sad guys gents gents ahah dave
was going to do a podcast - oh no yeah
no no Brian it's crushing it he's the
strongest player yet to ever grace
thanks now we got Ben Simon here I'm
just I'm wondering where I want your
feelings on astrology
well Ben's a Pisces Yeah right are you
playing with a delay erinc of it this is
final
this is rated some caveman chess yeah
I voted for hatred real myheart well
thank you oh stop lifeguard you don't
count yeah well they watch on YouTube
though they don't notice there's Isaac
see Danny this actually happens to me a
lot here really yeah
where's the neck oh all right watch this
is Ryan the club manager yes
how many people we got watching this 63
are they more twitchers or they'll each
essers well I don't think there's Anglia
Chester's anymore except for well I
assume all these people they are
watching it if they are watching it on
HS that it still counts as a number
there because it's just embedded in
whatever we know we just as providing
interesting so do they so that if they
work together their software works
together that's crazy
cuz I like Lee Chester's I don't like
Twitter this is a weird place for you
why don't you like the Twitter's third
everybody talking Wow we're live I know
but how do you really feel I'm gonna get
on here one of these days and teach
these twitches a lesson lesson two
million right draw blitz games in first
minute now he'll deals and Danny told me
for my queen here so I'm doing a lot of
manoeuvre ignite and I should have gone
to g6 where it has got for ya Knight to
g6 f4 which attacks the Queen and like
you're attacking is kinky stuff
I felt Ben Simon is a heretic yeah
surprised the twitchers didn't agree
with you all right so so did you just
call a successful of humanity ouch that
Mike actually works quick attack
something
I knew look we works in the middle don't
get oh yeah do it don't get forked
everybody you're playing mister don't
get for it he's gonna fork you 100%
every time you're never gonna miss a
fork oh yeah sound I love the sound
your stuff needed checkmate checkmate
how in the world can I can I put my
queen here Danny
first first wait what no I feel like
you're single you're the best and then I
check well then we know that we just
think about and also Texas pawneean
threatens me just take something once I
capture something Luke says I'm a leech
Esther with a twitch account for
watching chests streamers yeah how do
you feel
Luke Luke Luke to Hazzard so he's is
that a Dukes of Hazzard
alright alright later then Simon tell ya
if you guys had a deep questions for Ben
ya feelin well people weren't talking
Ben is now gonna go to church and then
he's going to the Church of the zodiac
like g5 will check me home for sure for
sure it's gonna be checkmate next move
for sure
how could he stop us
I am definitely said before if I keep
waiting we could just end it now yes
he's in and out gaming crushed everyone
else Wow thank you LDS that's what now
nobody matches we can't get done today
all right guys it's three to stuff you
play any Pat sir who was dumb enough to
want to get forked well do ya that's
what we only play any pastor who is dumb
enough to want to get four I don't think
he and I was not coming I think he just
got word yeah I mean you can't see these
things coming did you sneak up on you
everybody's playing that d4
also when people do these like exclams
and then like some keyword do we have
all that like enabled so people can do
explain him up time and then it like
tells you the uptime no we don't mean
buts
like we should we should hey I don't
know what other things people would want
other than enough time but it's like oh
hey guys I tell you how long he's been
on besides uh grandmasters playing what
else do you want to see on our twitch
yeah it's pretty open-ended what can go
some we can do we could do some birth
charts okay I'm tarot readings good yes
that's my class can we talk about this
on previous player just wondering should
I get in line yes of course we're
looking for three minutes Alan jizz
right now there's not a cyma with
viewers that's an excellent to know we
can we do that can we do it more Mike
100% Bocuse is right every Friday we'll
get Mike so that's a wait two more days
to see my camera in action
oh he's in it was take here may be a
sign mobile viewers lessons yeah so it
does also it depends on the streamer
some are obviously gonna be more
educational than others some are just
gonna be purely entertainment some are
gonna be purely educational and a lot of
it will be in the middle so so I'm not
sure we want to do any lessons because
those are we already do and put on
YouTube but I do like the idea of doing
a simulcram twitch lessons sounds good
and pretty much don't believe it
open-ended to like the GM stew that come
in because obviously they can just play
the people but some people for some
reason don't like you know playing and
they can analyze your games they could
do like a agitation of our class lesson
if they wanted to they can to kind of do
whatever they want with their their
segments we'll get them in here for
about 90 minutes and we're just starting
now so who knows how much twitch will
grow can you create your own tournaments
only chess yeah so you can create a
tournament and then is it okay so it's
not ass I'm all your everybody's playing
everybody but you just happened to be in
you have your own tournament might not
win your honor or you do you have to
enter your own tournament you just set
it up and we to spectate other people
that way you don't have to play any
chess and you never lose you know right
we met with maka people and then we
don't actually play with
we just make fun of those that do this
we're not all perfect like Ryan Chester
I've never seen Ryan lose a game ever so
I think yeah no I heard yeah hopefully
he's up there watching he's getting some
tips okay why I mean oh yeah maybe
Preston is watching right now Preston if
you were watching deep discovered attack
coming
yep against arrow check black so that's
the logo I can't share it with people
well so you can explain the Karan's Cup
because that's coming on karyn's cup top
that I like it right yeah top ten
females in the world yeah we should chat
if they approve do you know I didn't
have somebody convinced on the YouTube
chat that Magnus was moderating any
moderating it yeah yeah it's not worthy
of this right gonna discover him Wow
he's gonna play Bishop takes f6
yeah okay well now you told them come on
check where are you at
interactive twitch lessons yeah I mean
that's also a possibility yes that's the
point what you do some opening something
that's true if I can't do it in a
classroom setting then I'll have to
reserve yeah I mean life thanks to also
it might turn up interesting but I call
sure all right like study my my openings
whatever I'm just like picking yeah
we're a patois so it'd be funny if I I'd
prepare like a whole new repertoire just
for playing streamers but I also stream
my friend and then I shall be no nose
would be interesting to do you two is
drunk lifeguard guy he's gone spam yeah
drunkard yeah he put all these
Oh who's next
a lot of bow sidled chess openings like
right now that work live Q&A like I said
something I could do just Club hosted
tournaments play more variants yeah yeah
every time we get requests for variance
problem is Danny Machuca is the crazy
house specialist would he hates the
camera that's why you can like me oh I
saw your eyes I saw Danny's eyes for one
second
but he's the crazy house expert unreal
level of crazy house ability but who
else plays like variance that's willing
to actually do it
good place for it yeah yeah if people
are into it I mean didn't give it a go
what's bored that's the one where you
have like a million pawns against all
these things now you Caleb to come to a
horde for us which Caleb okay look at
the seat must be Dan be Caleb with a
seat can I do Lib Dem because I kept on
a four player chess very end
yeah only chess always take stuff I
think for player chess is just a just
like common thing I do want to something
we couldn't stream on chess combo when
you do it on LI chess you get to put
your thing next to the screen everyone
knows you're streaming it's just I can't
have anything like that do people know
that you're streaming and they wait in
my diner and then it like makes sense
for you to actually be doing it on just
icon yeah and they've been good to us to
lead chess people great to us like this
Emma drink
minutes within minutes of resuming
they're like really yellow turn to your
street for the first time and they like
they found us
what's our average stream down day down
a sorry I think those people are waiting
to see it on YouTube because they
probably can't contain the excitement
you're playing the best chess getting
the least viewers this one's empty
so they promote our Channel
yeah I mean I mean to say I mean just we
should just play around do do chess calm
as well they're all so good to us
there's no night discoveries
daddy's favorite move night except some
don't find it red clap
so yeah I would be interesting um do you
guys I guess you guys all found us on
Lee chest so you probably prefer leave
this well maybe there's a whole nother
market out there for just outcome
we're just playing around yeah yeah
as we stream more and more we're gonna
explore different options
little you'd have to be on one platform
or the other it give you we just and
just complain against members on
different sites of different rating
systems we alternate every every game
trying to stay on as many TVs as
possible early chess TVs just accused
Yeah right clap playing way beyond his
or her rating well he's not though
that's the thing no they always play
better when you're like streaming it's
unfair everyone plays better than they
actually are when you do do you play
worse no like nervous no people I think
know if I think because if you're
playing somebody you know everybody's
watching like you all right so I feel
like they do play better you also
they're trying and you know we're like
talking around well that's right yeah I
think you should put your back good
primo leach s has a faster cleaner
smoother interface then what just icon
yeah I guess yeah and I like that we do
the dark mojo I you have to for this
because I always they just hate it yeah
everybody complains if it's like not
dark mode no one complains if it's not
light mode so you have to do dark mode
people don't complain the opposite way
my life in the light
magnus carlsen hates the dark mode okay
no I rest my case
yeah
even then he agrees do you agree to dark
mud yeah you're a shady guy so
the amateur player is now following
thank you how can we I want to it never
makes noise for following right and the
only way as I and when they subscribe to
make something right sorry so we got
about nine minutes left here so is this
last one or you got two more in you add
two more me let's see what you think
three two is this good luck no that's
for something might I put black every
time and then we're done
yeah they're trying to cheat you
probably that was my age five
nope boom Oh would you he didn't think
no exit they always take it this is a
Jacob thing know what you're doing here
well no only one stick you know what
you're up to
wait wait but you probably don't take
back you probably put d4 in just exactly
how you probably is a thing that any
place yeah this is probably more normal
not against just not calm or anything I
just before Lee chest and so yeah and it
figures the people that are watching Lee
trusts are on the site right now
watching us so which awesome it yeah it
just makes me wonder people are putting
on just like on right now prefer just
icon so be interesting to at least
sometimes not every times pal check out
just like and just see ya if numbers are
better we're switching it's 300 people
watching on just that gum you'd have to
make a switch
you get it fun playing aggressive
great up with next game that's pretty
fast something about it one can't get
one for activating yeah hey Jonathan
I watched Euler ki d video and he
managed to beat a 1900 and you're only
1400 well thanks u unic TV I'm glad I
could help
another success story eunuch TV I feel
like we should think about the way our
name sounds yes serial killers for sure
do not trust any time I see someone
using the light theme I assume their
circus I'll not be the opposite go come
on I'm on a roll I'm on the street do
you yeah you you can do it you don't
remember go faster you better to be
serviced it's gonna take you telling you
butters stuff it's terrible then what
but it's good to see you monster hunter
day night that was the end of it I mean
you have to do Queen J for Queen G if
you can't go to h5b go to g4
you don't know what he does this parrot
I'm talking about Magnus like you know
maybe he's a serial killer he plays in
light mode why would you why would you
be a serial killer if you play a light
bulb you would think but like most
horrible things obviously a serial yeah
all right Danny you got me into this
mess that being said I don't want to
talk about what I do on the weekends no
for losses immediately tonight ichijo
Danny you got me a job checked well just
move your king or move your Brooke
actually probably d1
the mill that night is hanging in the
line were black it's gonna take it you
went through London I did you're gonna
sign Leonard now flag em so every time
we do this we get lots of people
following following okay so I assume
following means you see if whenever
we're streaming I'm assuming I don't
know no I think it just alerts you when
we look at me like a you right so why
what what does subscriber do what's the
difference in what is it matter why
would you just right is it just to
support them is it purely uh Danny I'm
gonna do this is that the only different
diverse are supporting us monetarily and
followers are just is that the only
difference or is there like subs can use
your chat LOL no does that mean everyone
here is this up and zero are followers
is that what that means subscription
means you pay five bucks a month for ad
free viewing in a most do we have ads so
we like well get access to emotes and
they support the stream
followers just to keep track up streams
you want to see subs get emotes that's
worth five bucks a month
get him we might get him here
[Laughter]
do you have some gels which it has meds
we need seven go yeah I don't think our
channel is old enough to be
grandfathered into not having ads for
subs and is that a thing you get
overtime I mean we've had this channel
for a while because we've done new you
know Grantchester where we've done
like out Shran says emotes what is that
the most now they used to be a thing but
they changed it once which got so big
Danny I only remember how Danny lost
this game and that's all I'm gonna take
away this has over 10,000 followers it's
not bad at all
yeah I mean cuz we do we do love the
Grinch s to her stuff on here so should
be like ah good job each other check me
you were playing Danny mature with that
entire time the first to be Danny would
chuckle ah a stress last one I'm not
listening to dad anymore who's got this
hurry
who's got a 303 we haven't lost yet
incredibly premium not lost the game you
have not which is the main takeaway from
this video hey guys how are you all
good to see you Thomas Scott now you're
joining us just for the last game so
this is Ryan Chester club manager who
will be here on Wednesdays doing the
stream and such tomorrow Thursday's that
will be the genome and Reza's visit will
be Dinesh morose and on Friday obviously
Mike commerce saving best for last I
usually do things on Tuesdays but I will
be on vacation the next two Tuesday's
because you guys crushed me so much
yesterday I need at least two weeks off
and was filling in been someone told me
but like I was a big dependent who was
filling in from Perry Perry yeah okay so
at least next usually that actually I'm
scheduled all right Lexi worgen meet
quantex but I lost two minutes
technically Danny was feeding the moves
- uh yeah Danny lost - regular somebody
but I beat Qantas 110 percent not only
did we not lose we beat him yeah okay
Oh a drunk lifeguard could fill in too
who would be funniest with Barry that's
the real question
thanks fish eh yes I mean it is four
times a week they were doing the stream
so and we're only starting starting oh
no I haven't you got a thing pretty much
do us well all right Dione you're next
no don't do it please
all right let's finish this up I don't
never lose I don't lose I've never lost
never still watching my last reel don't
watch my last rule right oh it took
something you need to take me back I'm
very excited you're just that good
you could have taken this you knew as a
trap all right but I must be up material
thus winning I don't know but it's Esley
there okay super checkmated he's gonna
live today do I have to I don't wanna
get checkmated I'm really scared of me
checkmate it's one of the things I hate
in life man please it's got good
compensation more at least more than I
would like but here we are finishing it
up Brian lost on time no never I've
never seen Ryan Lewis also history was
army quick he's gonna be in and out is
I'm even doing here what's my plan
my idea is if he takes us whatever this
rook moves away somewhere this thing
will be hanging which will depend this
thing
the Big D never hello good a trade I do
like training
let's get this guy in just in case
get a little defense gun Gary you know
this is this or that's right these
things are hanging all right now
Hey look look how many viewers are
watching now suddenly they're having a
spike in popularity so he's gone now you
guys can tell us how you honestly feel
was this a great stream or the best
stream you've ever seen in your life in
my mind the best I've ever seen
well yeah again I do want to thank all
the chat and everything everyone's
always been great you guys are just
fantastic a little more trolling next
time please it wasn't like high levels
of trolling on the stream
I think twitch usually needs to be
encouraged because they're usually
unlike whatever Bensimon says they're
always good people yeah I don't know
what's people that guy is on about cuz
as far as I've ever noticed in being
serious about the chest part like
they've just never been bad which it
helps it makes it a little bit easier
when you guys are just behaving and it's
not like an issue so I do want to thank
everybody in the chat dubs good to see
ya flex and he's flexing on ya Dums has
been working out he subs no he should
stuff he should know dubs lonely selves
no dubs only subs yeah it is been our
motto chess attracts a slightly older
crowd and I guess fewer trolls yeah
yeah it seems right but well yeah we
should sort of challenge against another
streamer okay
yeah who-who should we take on first
simply making random what's going on and
also if I don't like do anything direct
and check me this guy at the game will
just last forever and we can keep
talking we could take up Rosa do you
guys know about just position trainer
it's an opening program yeah it's dead
it's dead know about chess of all it's
all what testable chess position
trainers never updated
you made a move
we'll do some stuff this will attack
this somehow
so now we'll sneak in here somehow we
don't have to wear +4 look shows me I'm
a bishop attorney returns I will at the
optimal moment is okay he's gonna
release enough that yeah I hey I think I
have position trainer five or maybe four
five it was great until I found testable
then just like I don't mind your how
we're talking to red clap who played
quite well thank you right clap for for
challenging us today we're trying to
make this game lasts forever otherwise
we gotta endless dream what would he do
you want to finish this one out there
I'll first one game out alright well
only if they want do you guys want Perry
to play one more game you better tell us
now we're about to end this thing one
more game
yes or no see your circuit wait the
first person that answers that's the
answer okay if one person wants Perry
alright boy Perry this guy was so
excited that he resigns just to get
ready to see very nice that's so excited
alright everyone wants Perry alright one
more game alright don't let us down
alright and was super undefeated I see
that yeah I heard you lost cuz you made
him sack Supply Center and the
unconfirmed rumor is that you'll be
filling in for me next Tuesday I am I am
on my big vacation
I am me Perry Coulson plays the peoples
sounds good - it just sounds good
oh no the only person that is not into
it
Boo Berry someone booed me
two high rated for you guys or something
yeah you're not too high rate and we
never lose Ryan played all 2800 sin one
easily every game this guy's talking
about while doing tarot readings
what are they just warming up this is
every week sort of situation we're just
warming up
prepare you'll be playing tonight in the
Knights I am I'm in on the board three
tonight all right word three this
evening Oh big shame Lucas never got
challenged yeah I agree with that um
yeah the problem is yeah he was here
he's very active in the chatter saying
good things and yeah not everyone gets
into play it was most of the other ones
are a 90-minute show this was just a 60
minute show but yeah we we decreased the
time control which means more people got
to play at least a little bit but we'll
have to get back to you Luke
between two more games three three more
it's okay I'll get you next time gadget
etc just Luke is it Luke Dee what's
going on with your name Luke D hazard my
middle initial is D last name hazard is
that your real last name yeah we play
chess dubs
Jonathan Franz tells me put my rooks on
open files so well kalpen find one
person on our YouTube channel said that
is yeah my real name
I am USCF rated player no one believes
it let's check them out
and also the unfortunate bit then is
everybody knows your real name maybe
look D hazard has nothing to hide see
Luke hazard where you at
1,700 perfect from New York alright
all right so if you want you can play it
you can play Luke he was good in the
chat all day Wow he's giving his full
name hopefully hopefully nothing bad can
happen if you give your full name on the
Internet
[Music]
I just need the address and social
security number please
yeah throwing mother's maiden name all
the time ah check out Luke D hazard you
may be during the New York area
yeah check him out let's see Luke
hazard music whoa look at a million
songs popped up
well it's really you he's available on
Pandora Wow I'm afraid to click these
things but want to watch it not on the
stream Wow
what well yeah what - what - allow this
one for the people at home to see what a
dub said it looks like that might be the
case yeah yeah see had this is why we're
not clicking on it because it you know
it looks like that might be the one in
question
oh now we added the permitted tank F
followed by all those things
all right that is him yeah see you
change that page but yeah that's him yes
so yeah we'll have to play this Luke a
so you're not done yet
oh no see you play piano
get the piano players good that pawn is
protecting your night
see what that thing's your name
does it yep
we have a big trick go to see one Hill
for sure play rook takes pawn and you'll
play Queen takes his rook for sure
that'll happen
Queen c1 never see one look see one it's
a rose playing go see one look see one
well I just don't like doing is playing
for one dumb trick it's not I'm not
actually playing the most
no no help Anna ball doesn't find rook
takes t4 no don't listen to us I was a
bad trick Jonathan what's the problem
you still might doing my work
do work what can you do can you do Saxon
takes e5 just take something just take
stuff
whoever you want to do you're the man in
charge you gotta get used to making
these decisions we're gonna play Tuesday
danger stranger danger
Thanks
faster it's five-o so you actually got
speed to something some have called you
busted position I'm probably not in
position but on the pretty take it
except all the concentrates all the
consequences on we accept all the
consequences whatever they're doing we
just whatever we accept
that's got to move fast
Nest there's no increment so go fast
no Luke poor Luke you might come back
under a different account now Luke do
you still have a challenge out cuz we
can play it we can play one more game
just stretch this thing out hopefully I
didn't have to go to this four o'clock
meeting whatever it is make sure I don't
have to be somewhere right now not sure
six new emails too much work to do not
enough time
[Music]
go do something fast checkmate me no no
I'm not fine you find it on the border
on time all right
told you all right good game by Hannibal
thanks Hannibal
all right look for Luke though we'll
play one last game and we'll say our
goodbyes sir
don't worry Tubbs is laughing at you but
that's alright alright Luke Hazzard give
them a go alright so yeah but after this
we do gotta wrap this up so this is your
chance then you play faster thanks Rio
when you play on Tuesday what time
controller you can play
you never know dubs never know
well yeah it was a pretty good stream if
you're just joining us at the very end
Ryan beet absolutely everybody like
super easy and convincingly Ryan played
really well for I guess very probably a
lot I write of the room a little bit
played well Ryan played really well yeah
yeah right around there he's 1033 rated
in actually I mean he played a lot of
really big in today so look forward to
seeing him and asking any questions that
you want to ask the manager for chess
club and yeah looking forward to
tomorrow Fishbourne OSHA's very first
stream as far as I know I don't think
he's ever streamed Jess so he'll be here
playing the people come play Grandmaster
Welsh and Friday Mike coming it doesn't
get any better
so as the week goes on the lineup just
gets better and better so I'll be here
this week yeah yeah so I'll be here
tomorrow
I don't be ya know my wife's going out
of town and due to the schedule for my
kids at school usually I can like work
and then just take the kids for the
morning and pick them up after but I
can't do it this time so I'll have to
take a vacation and just stay home with
the kids
it whatever keep going cuz I got to us
Oh lost McQueen I wasn't thinking
whenever whenever mommy goes out of town
it's getting worse but let's keep
playing
we always have a party we go to Party
City we get lots of balloons in the dark
parties yes mommy's out of town no this
is good you got this oh yeah this guy
right here
yeah I know it's really bad but
everything else we do you want more of
this come back on Tuesday what was he
very could get crushed again you know
about as good as this
on Tuesday hey my name is Joey you're
here just in time all right
okay see it be okay Luke yeah I do think
everybody watchin the stream and come
back tomorrow what time is it tomorrow
Central Time yeah comer tomorrow 3:00
3:00 p.m. and it's not covered its
master you Grand Master tomorrow all
right
so thanks everybody go watch it on
YouTube unless you're on YouTube give us
a like share and subscribe and thanks
everybody for all the games today